our text system is broken Lux leagues
and Panama papers show how big
corporations and rich individuals
exploit legal loopholes shop around for
the lowest tax rates and hide their
money in Duchy tax havens by ending tax
abuse and tax crimes we left billions of
euros to invest in a fair and
sustainable economy especially after the
twelve eight nineteen crisis the time
for tax justice has come we want to
shine light on top into the side the
plastics of touch abuse and fix our
broken tax system as socialists and
Democrats we have pushed hard for a
permanent toxic committee in the
European Parliament we are proud that
this committee will no war as a war
stock and people's forum for tax tax
avoidance is eating big holes into our
budget the escalating race to the bottom
for the lowest tax rates must be stopped
or else corporate taxes will be pushed
lower and lower at people's expense it's
time that big companies pay their fair
share of tax and to put an end to fiscal
dumping large digital companies like
Google Facebook or Amazon pay really low
taxes we are socialists we strive for an
international solution but if it does
not come to you must advance on its own
it is time we play a fair game again
plastic and kerosene are not taxed as it
should be even though the poison or soul
or water and or F big polluters like the
maritime and aviation must pay while we
make sure the poorest household
I'm not met to disproportionately bear
the costs of the ecological transition
in a world of multinationals and global
flows of money together as the EU we
have more power to act on the wishes of
our citizens if we improve the decision
making by moving slowly away from
unanimity voting rules on all tax issues
so that the service can no longer block
measures that serve the common good
[Music]
we are ready to fight to end destructive
tax competition to investigate
- crimes it is time let's tax digital
companies fairly it is time our tax
policies catch up with our ambitions in
the fight against climate emergency it's
time for tax justice
[Music]